hello you have asked and we have
listened and we are finally releasing
our very first merch campaign for big
mood time ever and this particular
design is a very limited time for
Valentine's Day design for the first two
weeks of February and for those of you
listening and don't not looking at the
video right now it's the cutest design
you'll ever see it's like a little
sweetheart with our mood in the middle
of this part and it's like one of those
like candied heart yes as big mood it's
super super cute on this is honestly my
favorite design - so cute and the fact
that it's limited - I'm like oh my gosh
we need to order everything because we
even have mugs with the exact same
design there's like pullover like
crewnecks seriously I'm jealous of what
everyone else got because we each only
got to pick two items yeah I'm looking
at everyone else's that I'm like I gotta
get that super cute but like Nicky said
it's super limited you can order this
until Valentine's Day okay want one you
better get one or if you're you know if
you want something for your girlfriend
for your mom for your sister tell them
or for you I mean like rocket yeah
rocket did but get it while you can
because it's very limited and if you
want to check out all the different
colors and designs go to teespring comm
slash stores slash big mood they'll be a
link in the description check it out
take an actual mouton getcha mood
yes mood where do I even look at you can
look at there or there and all the
beautiful faces out there yeah who could
we have on today I'm Nikki limo I'm
Julia chow
yeah speaking of beautiful faces look at
Julia's chow I'm such a fan I'm Julia
I'm a blow you up for a minute I always
be looking at her she had these big ol
eyes these nice lips perfect skin oh my
god I love Julia she's right into both
fantasies here please tell me more so my
eager luscious lips I need to know
sensual nipples I literally look at
Julia's pictures sometimes on Instagram
and I'll be like too beautiful and I
just scroll I get really upset sometimes
I'm like oh just DoubleTap it pretty
you're glowing you are here with us
today
welcome to the bedroom yeah the big food
bedroom love it it's really cute I love
it thank you
obviously yeah some people a little too
much over here yeah I think I feel like
Beau's is like my number one fan woman
maybe yeah number two one fan is Mike
Nelson mouths eyes I don't think so oh I
don't think Nelson's remember one fan
it's actually us together bows and your
number one is Jess and both fan club you
just don't even know about yeah yeah
minion fan whatever bows and just say
president level do it number three is
Nikki limo button in a minion costume
[Laughter]
started so today Julia so a lot of
people out there watching if they're
familiar with you of you what familiar
with you from JK news a lot of people
watch do you kind of grow up and blossom
into your own adult self online like
through the cameras and I know that for
a lot of people you felt like everyone's
little sister for a long time like David
would always say that and Jo and Bart
from JK news and when I was first
introduced to the group it was always
like oh that's like our little sister
yeah and but then little sister grew up
and you've been posting like beggin
picture like she is coming to it into
her own you were I'm gonna just say
we're so more sexy now you're as sexy as
[ __ ] and the first couple times I was
like I was like damn where did this come
from she was hiding on it yes absolutely
I've been shocked in the last what is it
like maybe six months to a year yeah
ever since you've been dating Nelson you
have gotten way sexier and I don't know
it's just be like you're happy in that
relationship he's making you more
confident you guys are most probably
having good sex when I kind of get into
it but whatever is happening like into
it it's creating this this beauty it's
coming out of you like you're always
beautiful but you're always more cute
and now you're like on fire but then
you've mastered the whole like cuteness
and now you've leveled up and yeah yeah
my egos growing too big and I feel like
I'm shying away from it
we want we want we and everyone out
there we want some advice from you I
mean I think all of us were at some
point pretty awkward yes definitely I
was always I was definitely ugly
duckling no you were pretty much fine
dude no idea how ugly ugly duckling was
but then you show us like old pictures
um more like uh where's the ugly part of
the duck yeah like she wouldn't bully me
but so did Nicky to learn one of your
pictures actually George can we eat
throughout this if we mentioned you
think can we put a picture of us up on
the screen me crying eating candy and
bows was like you look like you could
bully me for that but yeah we know how
did you yeah we want to know like what
are your [ __ ] secrets how did you
reach that inner glow up that then
expanded to the outer were you do you
feel like you were more cutesy and
awkward about sexuality before and then
changed or do you think did you don't
even notice the glow up hmm I don't know
I feel like a part of me didn't really
notice the globe because I feel like it
was a lot of things that were in my head
for the most part and I think growing up
I always kind of felt like I never
wanted to be behind on a lot of things
so and what I mean by that is like oh
behind on like talking about sex or
behind on like any anything that's like
happening in the world like any trend
that's happening I always feel like I'm
behind on it right and I think because
of that I've started to just tell myself
that's like oh you're always behind
you're always behind and so I think it
was just like would be detrimental to
like how I thought about everything like
a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah exactly
and so then I so then when I was what
what is it what I keep thinking like oh
dude you're being so awkward right now
like I was actually living the awkward
life so I was like
reality yeah so I don't know how the
globe happened but I think it's just as
time went on I just started feeling
really good about myself that's so cool
I remember you telling me a story on the
plane like when we went to Tulum
together we went on a girls trip to
Tulum over a year ago now yeah legit I
feel like that was the first time I
actually talked to you yeah true I spent
the whole plane ride next to each other
yeah and I got to hear all a lot about
like your high school high school Julia
South and from what we were relating on
is that we were both [ __ ] weirdos
yeah in high school and that girl it was
I can't picture being sexy or it was
that would really bum me out because let
me just say when I get on an airplane I
have set myself up to be a lone for X
amount of time and then if I realize I'm
sitting next to a friend and I have to
talk for like three four or five hours
I'll be like oh [ __ ] any of y'all know
y'all remember we went out that one time
and I put my headphones in and I was
like I need to be alone for 20 I don't
have to talk I was on the other aisle
with TIFF and Gio and we didn't talk the
whole time but [ __ ] really show that I
even booked Steve see away from me so I
don't have to talk I just like listen to
my music and and and sleep but I will
say that because I never really got like
to connect to Julianne before like we
never went out to dinner we she was
always somehow not in the other group
stuff yeah we were yeah and I was in
charge of the invites okay Julia I
promise you I was just an attendee but
we never really got to like connect on
that level so it was really cool to
actually and I was in I was like pretty
awake and not needing to unplug because
we did a lot of unplugging in actual
Tulum where we got to like just chill on
the beach and relax
so yeah on the flight home getting to
hear these stories but I want you to
tell it because I just to give a picture
to everybody out there of like the type
of person you were in high school yeah
man I feel like the person that I was in
high school was definitely a lot more
shy but always wanted to engage with
people just because I felt like I was
never cool enough to have friends
that's legit what I thought in high
school so like whenever like somebody
comes and like invites me to something I
feel like really you want to hang out
with me oh okay yeah yeah definitely go
so like that's like legit high school
giulio where it would take her oh yeah
I'm thankful for whoever wanted to be
friends with me but this is just
something that I personally noticed like
when I went on my first trip with like
JK like I don't you I can't believe you
guys invited me the Vegas trip what the
[ __ ] from each other so Jeana was the
year right before me and then I was next
to and I felt the same way and then you
were the next year and it's so
surprising because like I said new
friends River and then I'm like well
when we were in Vegas and I remember
this like to me Julia when I first met
you it was on JK party and you're the
host of JK party like your cast you're
in front of the camera and I knew you
also were on news for a while too you
have like this massive following and I
noticed that when we went to Vegas ever
like a lot of the it was like not really
clicky but I guess it's because like
these people know each other the most I
noticed that the cast kind of sat at a
specific table because we're literally
talking to each other non-stop forever
and then the production crew kind of sat
in a certain table cuz yeah they're
always talking to each other and then
Julia got her food and walked over and
she went to like the production table
and so I was like oh is Julia closer to
that side like do you did you ever like
assert yourself into like certain groups
like because in my eyes I'd be like oh
yeah Julia probably would sit here with
all of us but you know you sat over at
Kass and I felt like I usually saw
something similar happen
ya know most definitely because I work
with them a lot I'm actually a lot more
comfortable like sitting with them yeah
but like in terms of sitting with cast I
think I for me like
I get along well but then I don't think
I hundred percent click be just because
our lives are just different like we
grew up very differently and then I also
feel like our interests are very
different too so like the anime kids or
one table and then they're like kids
that like to say [ __ ] a lot or at the
other team yeah but also you know I'm
not really at that stage of like I have
a family or like I'm trying to buy a
house okay you know you know so so to me
is like oh like those are like adult
talking right now like like I feel like
I kind of see in you like you see
yourself in a certain way and then you
make that like a reality to and then I
feel like somehow at some point like
you've just gotten very confident in
yourself and you're like you're like I'm
not gonna put myself in a bubble I'm
just gonna be yeah like does that make
sense yes normally yeah she was like I
don't care what what what table or what
group were you where I am in your mind
I'm just me yeah yeah too sexy
to be honest it's hot like it with
whatever glove that you guys are
witnessing I would say it's probably
thanks to you guys just because I'm
surrounded by you guys and like you got
to try see you guys do so many things
and like I reflect I was like what am i
doing in my life right now
like am I even like making the best out
of my life like am i using all the
things that I have like to the best of
its abilities and so I just sit there
and reflecting like you know yeah why do
I have to stay in the state that I am
you know like if I'm being a bomb why do
I have to still be a bum like I don't
have to be above anymore like I can I
can like dress up and look pretty or I
can play with makeup or you know I can
just do things I've always been
interested in but always afraid to do I
think that's interesting because I felt
that way before too it's like oh I'm
always the one that's in kind of like
tomboy clothes or I'm always like just
wearing t-shirts and jeans and then so
like when I try to be cute or pretty or
whatever it just feels so weird and it's
like oh you don't belong in that so why
are you even
those were the stories that we tell
ourselves so if you grew up being like
well I'm the tomboy one on the tomboy
when I'm a tomboy then you already like
limit yourself like I wouldn't try that
makeup or that you know because that's
not my type that I've decided that I was
ten years ago you know and then when
I've seen it from you to just
experimenting with stuff that you don't
normally experiment with and it's done
wonders like I'm like whoa Jess you're
[ __ ] hot yeah thank you I've noticed
like for me personally I'm taking it
like a little bit slowly like I I don't
feel like I ever had like a massive glow
up or anything but it started like I
dyed my hair blonde I was like you know
I've always been this brunette very dark
and brooding type of chick and then so
now I'm just kind of like okay let's try
to lighten it up so I'm she's nice so we
started with the hair and then slowly
I've been like so I'm still not like the
one to wear a lot of dresses are like
have a lot of jewelry and be like super
feminine but like the I'm so I'm still
wearing a lot of like long sleeves and
pants but I'm like making them like more
girly yeah so just like little things
like that and I think it's helping my
confidence even though I can't really
fully like become this hot girl that I
wish that I was like I you see all these
LA girls and you're just like oh I kind
of wish I could do that but I don't
think it really fits me legit when you
first came to the company I was like
dresses like my long-lost sister because
I felt like we had like like even though
we were very different people I didn't
feel like we had certain things in
common just how my yeah yeah so I was
like oh like like I can fight with Jess
but then I know that we didn't really
hang out very much but L think but
that's how we are met her at a
restaurant after we know Jake a new
shoot oh you walked up with that [ __ ]
face [ __ ] like she comes up and she's
just like and I was like you look like
Mila Jovovich
yeah I like she's like it was brooding
but it was like hot and not wait it like
you know how some guys they're like I
literally want you to crush my ballsack
like that's how I felt like grew balls
and I want to just to step on my
testicles that's how I felt the first
time I met you the first time I met you
you are so dry dry humored but like
because you're delivery so dry and
you're also very smart like your whip
smart yeah you had the like dark
brunette hair I was like this is like
one of those hot politicians like you
you look like really good but then like
you just like so knowledgeable like
intelligent that I'm like you're a
politician like god damn where's the
valley for Jessica I think that's a
relatable thing Serbia is like you both
went through the first time in that
Juliette can I be honest I thought she
owned JK because yeah because you know
like I've been on YouTube for a while
but and I've heard of JK phones but I
didn't I didn't never like watch it or
know who owned it or anything like that
I've heard of them and then when you
guys reached out to me through a fellow
youtuber because you were running the
emails and then you were hosting the
show like usually in the YouTube world
if it's your YouTube channel you are
hosting the show so I thought that since
you reached out and you hosted it was
your channel and the other people were
just like I think it's really
interesting for us to share what we
thought of Julia first because Julia
talked about how she felt about herself
she's been like oh I felt like I wasn't
cool or like something like that and
then here we are thinking like we
thought you on the [ __ ] job first
time I met Julia
I actually met Jake hey through Smosh
and I have to say guys don't before I
say this don't get any ideas of like
castes and stuff because there's many
people behind the scenes in front of and
behind the camera who knows but when I
first met her these two guys that I
worked with were obsessed
yeah they they literally thought she was
the most beautiful woman well and I
remember one day somebody somebody had
said something we were editing a video
and like somebody had said like I'll cut
that frame out something and like I
think that they took it as like somebody
said something mean about you they
really didn't but then one of the guys
did and he was like hey don't what do
you mean she's she's really cool like
he's not like defensive about you and
like anytime you would post a picture
yeah and so like this girl like for me I
was like oh of course I thought you were
really sweet you're really cute but it
was interesting for me to see these two
guys go nuts over like your innocence
and like how sweet you were too jealous
of you being Julia's number-one fan
wanted that spot dude but yeah like
thinking about stuff like that's funny
because Julia just like felt like oh I'm
awkward and these guys like this is the
most beautiful woman in the world that
would die yeah so what did the story
start changing for you like when did you
start like being like oh actually I
don't have to be in this box hmm I think
honestly it started when when I started
working for a JK yeah because um I think
even during that time prior to joining
them my mentality was actually pretty
closed off to a lot of the things and I
think for me watching JK in general is
like oh I should really open my mind up
to different things and then so then as
soon as I got the company I was like wow
I can't believe that happened I'm like
holy [ __ ] I'm in a room full of my idols
I was like feeling that way and I was
like okay don't [ __ ] this up don't [ __ ]
this up like you're gonna be cool man
you're gonna be cool and so then as I
started integrating into the company I
was like oh cool like I love it you know
we're like a family we all kind of get
along we work together right and it's
not even a bad workflow - it's like how
often can I say that I play games for
work
not very often yeah yeah that's pretty
cool so being around everybody in JK I
think really helped me open up a lot
more and just be oh I don't know how do
I say it's just like try to explore new
things I never thought I would actually
find myself doing yeah mm-hmm Oh would
you did you ever explore trying things
like fun
he sucks like bomba fear cold do me tell
me you don't shop with this on wiki feet
are you asking for it like they look at
my butt don't you know I've seen that
and I think they have tabs on everybody
oh yeah they do yeah they do I just
looked at your feet I was like watch out
watch out what can I cover my feet with
well okay talking about our feet porn
site but Boas are the most comfortable
socks in the history of feet did you
know that they're made from super soft
natural cotton and every pair comes with
arch support a seamless toe and a
cushion foot bed that's comfy but not
too thick all right we have a very huge
bulbous fan it's Tiffany she's not here
but she would tell you that she
absolutely loves them oh she's good oh
she's here she's gonna come tell us Boas
are what feet daydream about guys voted
for my feet as the best sock and for
every bonus purchase you make they
donate a pair to someone in need I love
that but seriously though because I
don't know if everyone knows but don't
like the number one thing that people
ask for like for homeless donations is
socks yeah people think of pants I think
of shirts all the time they need socks
they do so you guys can try a pair by
your bomas at bombas comm slash mood and
get 20% off your first purchase
that's vom bas comm slash mood for 20%
off bombas comm slash mood and well you
got your comfy socks on kick up your
feet and order some food yeah make sure
you put it on a rolling chair so that
while your cookie keep that foot up but
you should cook with hellofresh
let me tell you why I'm waiting on my
delivery right now I've been waiting
I've literally been checking my email
for that overnight shipment thing that's
like your delivery will be in tomorrow
and then I don't have to go to the
grocery
for the whole week I get a big pack so I
have some 4i I live on my own so I make
my dinner I make the whole thing I'm
having something for dinner and then I
have something for lunch the next day
yeah it's great meal Preppers yes order
it or changes your life yes you prep too
oh yeah oh my god I love it it's
perfectly portioned they don't waste
anything it makes cooking delicious and
regardless of your comfort in the
kitchen you'll have everything you need
to get a WoW where these dinner I'm not
kidding like I'm reading this paper but
like I believe it it's true it's soul
fire they have more five-star recipes
than any other meal kit and you know
that you're gonna get something
delicious like you get to know that
yeah we're ham and it's it's always it's
healthier it's flexible you can add
extra meals to your weekly order change
the delivery days food preferences and
you can skip a week if you're going out
of town one of my personal favorite
recipes that I've tried oh my god it's
so good it's a it's a chicken breast
that is breaded on top and it's baked so
it's super healthy and then it came with
like a zucchini with like a garlic aioli
no yeah it was so good today it was
honestly so good that recipe made me
absolutely obsessed with hellofresh
yeah so get the most meal for your moola
go to hello fresh comm slash big mood
ten and use code big mood ten for ten
free meals including free shipping again
go to hell afresh calm slash big mood
ten and use code big mood ten and get
ten free meals including free shipping
so Hulya yeah I have a question for
Julio yeah I don't know if this is
presumptuous or if this is hurtful or
anything but we're talking about glowing
yes sir I want to ask you know I don't
like to never want to offend her how did
you feel during the phase where you cut
all your hair off because I know for a
lot of girls that's like a really very
crazy thing like like they'll be really
excited about it and then they'll get
reactions to it and then they'll feel
like their entire femininity is lost or
something like that but you actually
recut your hair several times you kept
it you're like no I like this hairstyle
I [ __ ] loved it man
see here's the thing when you cut your
hair short you have to be prepared for
it like you gotta want it like if your
hair is short and you don't want it it's
gonna be a miserable time
so like I've always wanted to try out a
pixie cut just because I feel like the
the ladies who rock it looks so bad yes
they look so good
yeah but then like and then there's a
whole debate where guys are just like oh
no but girls look good with like long
hair I'm like [ __ ] you are you girls can
rock any kind of haircut they want a
rock yeah it's about like
self-expression yeah yeah if you want to
be badass and you think that makes you
feel badass like yeah that's how you
makes you feel it doesn't matter what
the dudes feel yeah they're exactly it
took a lot of balls though yeah no I
remember when you do that I was like
damn she's way more badass than I
thought no I [ __ ] loved it dude like
I'm feeling good I'm like and shower
time went down by yeah yeah yeah so I
was just in the shower for like five
yeah yeah then you've never had to
straighten it or do anything else like
curly hair no but like there were times
where when I did have my short hair that
I kind of miss curling my hair but at
the same time like yeah how long did you
have the short hair for mmm maybe for
like about a year blue around the same
time right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's like a whole change yeah it was
like a change yeah dude I think I feel
like you guys had like on this nerdy
awkward phase I had an awkward - sexy
transition and yeah a little different
go go it's a little different so I I was
like really like awkward and kind of
like goth in high school um god this is
weird I feel like I'm articulating this
for the first time so like gather y'all
are getting it raw I had such low
self-esteem but I had a really great
body I've always had really good pretty
good body like I've always had like I've
I had tits ass and I was skinny and so I
hated myself a lot so I would show a lot
of skin and try to put on a lot of
makeup I always hate in my face but I
tried to make my face look better and I
would always show skin because it made
me feel like I was sexy but it's it's
because I I didn't like my personality I
thought that I was just like a literal
like waste of everything and so I was
like I thought my only redeeming quality
was my body so when I was 18 and up I
dressed very scantily clad lots and lots
and lots of makeup I'll have to get
pictures for this my goth makeup or like
no like hot girl makeup like suit I
would wear blue contact lenses like oh
yeah or green contact lenses like I like
tried to like really do it up I got to
find some pictures of this but I was so
incredibly insecure and awkward and I
feel like for guys they could just sense
this insecurity off of me like bro if
you were wearing way too much makeup
like in in you and you also are awkward
like if you're super sexy and confident
you have a long a lot of makeup that's
one thing but if you're like hunched
over and you can't even like walk
straight and you [ __ ] hit yourself it
doesn't match it doesn't match at all
and so I was like desperate awkward if
that makes sense it was like really it
was really weird and now that I think
about it so I had to like and I think
with Julia like we're asking like when
did it change and when I start to try to
think about that it just kind of
happened I just started to like myself
more and it just like slowly happened
but I think the biggest change that I
made was not focusing anymore on whether
people liked me or not just letting it
be and because that's much sexier I
think that when you use the word sexy
people think Oh a girl that's trying to
get sexual attention no it's when you're
like okay with your inner and you're
like I feel confident and SEC that's
when the sexy comes out and you're not
thinking about what does that person
think are they looking at me like you're
just like I feel good about myself and
then that's sexy I was awkward in a way
where I was always awkward in high
school in the like I was over very
overweight and I was goth and I had
braces and
just flashed into my mind maybe okay
maybe I might have seen on Instagram
yeah maybe I know not that way I know I
sighs my boyfriend he was like whoa
orange hair cuz I thought I would try to
highlight my hair but I couldn't afford
to go to a hair salon so I went to like
the beauty school where they do it for
free and they like me my hair patchy
Orange it was it was a wreck and then I
lost weight over the summer like a 1
year going in from junior year to senior
year I lost weight got the braces off
boobs got bigger I didn't know and and
then nice but I still felt like the same
awkward everyone no one has a crush on
me and no one likes me I used to want to
I used to crush on guys and get rejected
so much that I was just like nobody who
likes me and they all like my friend and
so then the next year everyone got
really nice to me
and I was just like wow guys got way
nicer senior year like they're just
nicer now and my friends like they're
hitting on you're like no no people
don't hit on me they never they didn't
that doesn't happen when I've been when
I moved to LA I still was not
comfortable with like my sexuality I was
very like even in a relationship having
sex we do like googoogaga voices it was
not sexy I was like baby talk like like
it was crazy like do you only do
missionary that's what I'm picturing um
we do doggy style too but I mean that
was just no I wasn't sexy though it
wasn't like hey come here it was like it
was like let me turn over now
boyfriends being like we're just two
little tiny bees yes and you would
cookies all go back to me and I'm like
and I remember going to acting class and
like I into a conservatory program and I
he was very about like let's get you
working right away and he liked all the
roles would that I was getting sent out
for where hot girl roles but it's like
the inner didn't match that and I was
like well I don't know why they keep
sending me out for these roles like I
wanted to go out for awkward neighbor
girl that comes and is like because you
know that's how I feel like that's all I
knew yeah like send me out for like hey
do you want to go back to my place like
like the hot girl cute stuff and I'm
like no and my acting coach was like
where's the disconnect like what the
[ __ ] is happening tell me about your
like he's like not to make it like
creepy but like how do you have sex at
home like was to what is I guess he is
and I told him he's like oh god and he
gave me affirmations like to do like you
have to say I'm a gorgeous voluptuous
woman in the mirror and I [ __ ] cried
he's like say it right now I was like
I'm a gorgeous voluptuous woman here I
he would only give me sexy scenes to do
in class I cried every single time I
went up because I'd be like hey like no
oh my god scary your sexy bootcamp
actually that's what I was gonna say is
I that wasn't the bootcamp but I signed
up for a pole dancing class Oh dancing
bootcamp where it was three days a week
three hours a day Oh for a month Oh they
taught me I thought it was gonna be like
how to look sexy to guys right because I
when I think sexy or when I think like
going out on auditions and being the
sexy girl it's like how do I be sexually
attractive no they [ __ ] opened a door
in me that was like sexually liberating
in a sense that I was like I [ __ ]
feel sexy they don't give a [ __ ] who's
looking at me and I like feel it in my
body and I was walking around the pole
the girl that walked into the first day
of that class versus the girl that
walked out of that last day so separate
woman Oh started booking roles on TV and
it was life-changing just and sex sex
got way better that guy yeah I went to a
boot camp like that I don't think it was
three hours a day three times a week or
anything like that I think I did one
hour a day four or one hour a day for
like a few weeks or whatever but just a
few hours that I was there it's like
because you're with these women who are
so confident yeah themselves like just
and there is no men in there it's like
you guys all being sexual in front of
each other yeah but you're all in your
own your own world there's no judgement
and they learn you you learn how to be
comfortable with your own sexuality and
like almost feeling the music in your
own way like without trying to look cool
dancing you're like I'm feeling it
almost like a like a meditation of like
some sexual goddess or something yeah
like the fire comes into you and you're
like yes yeah that's exactly
yeah because actually honestly even now
when I think about it I think I would be
awkward about something like that and
it's possible that maybe something
either needs to be unlocked or that
maybe that is not personally how I feel
sexy I'm not sure I'm open to it yeah
cuz I okay nice thing about it I did do
one pole dance class with my
sister-in-law actually but like I just
remember the whole time I was like Jim
those biceps when they just grabbed the
side of the bar like that yeah oh my god
okay this we like so irrelevant so guys
a fun fact I used to waitress out of
strip club we both were Hooters girls
too and also what was okay wait wait let
me backtrack yeah but so I it's
interesting you say that are your
sexiness came about with some of the
external that was poured in and not only
something external but you accepted that
external thing that was poured into you
for mine I worked at a place called the
melting pot it was a fondue restaurant
and I worked in the kitchen and I was a
dishwasher
both I did prep I did nighttime kitchen
it was mostly just prepping salads and
desserts and then one day I like because
I have a didi I was on adderall and I
was like I want to wash dishes so I was
the dishwasher and the kitchen girl and
I wanted more hours and then like they
wouldn't really give them to me so I
heard that at Hooters the cooks made
like $13 an hour or something crazy like
that and so I was like I don't think it
was 13 but it was way more than I was
getting paid yeah so I literally went
two blocks over and I applied to Hooters
do you remember the application would it
look like at all because I remember the
process so it's so the top of it was
just it was like Hooters girl hostess
kitchen and you just checked off a box
I checked off kitchen because that was
the only experience that I had and so my
first interview we can really agree you
don't have experience
I don't know this experience I go to my
first interview went great
they called me back and in the second
interview you have to try on the uniform
and I was like I'm applying for cook and
they were like what
my dumb ass being like no I could never
and who - broke up in my eyes they were
blonde all-american beautiful women body
yeah I mean like I it's like I
subconsciously knew I don't know it was
it's [ __ ] stupid I work at Hooters
are like fours and then half of them are
eights so I mean for sure you would I
got it also plot twist y'all I 3/4 of
them are married so calming down yeah
yeah so that that was my external saying
like no you are hot and I was like oh I
am hot and then I kind of forced myself
into this role because of yeah but now
back to the pole dance yeah so I briefly
worked as I when I was in Vegas I worked
at a TGI Fridays I lost my job because I
didn't ring up a soda somebody clearly
didn't [ __ ] like me yeah that's that
sounds petty yeah that's what it is
somebody didn't like me there which is
fine so I lost my job over that and my
roommate at the time who was a dancer
was like oh I can get you a job
cocktailing at like one of my like any
of the clubs cuz strippers work at like
multiple clubs and so I was like okay I
think my mom's just now finding out
about this guide like literally like no
I just was a cocktail waitress swear to
God why so my first day in there this is
a random pole dancing story and it's
like changed my life
my first in there I didn't do it but I
walking around and they give you like a
corset there was a uniform for all the
waitresses and so I feel kind of hot I
got to wear like fish and I live the
same life exactly what I went through so
there were there was one girl I
immediately came friends with it was
like a dominatrix and she was like not
that hot but when she would get on stage
she would put metal on and she would
like dance and like do all this crazy
stuff I was like wow she's so cool and
then this and then like there was like a
silence because like girls get to pick
their songs and go up and like this song
starts playing and it's like very like
triumphant and then like everyone starts
gathering around the stage and I'm like
what is what is happening and everyone's
gathering around and then this 6-foot
like three blonde woman they're like
women longest hair ever just
walks out and the beginning of I like
big but starts playing and it's like
that didn't and she's like walking up to
the pole and everyone's like and just
throwing money I'm like who the [ __ ] is
this
okay it like little did I know a week
later I'd watch ASA kerachut underwear
out of her vagina on stage okay but fast
word back to this woman so she's like
walking up to the stage all hot and I'm
like oh my god what is going on
everyone's going wild and she starts
climbing the pole and there's a second
pole the building was two stories she
climbed the pull all the way to the top
and like there was one point where like
just with her thighs she was like moving
up the pole and I was like what the [ __ ]
is going on and she gets to the top and
it's right when he goes I like big butts
and she just draws down the pole and
everyone starts throwing that I didn't
perform and I was like I literally need
to be this woman but I never did it like
I've never seen anything like that again
for the rest of my life and like she was
spinning as she came down like with her
thighs yeah I love her I literally miss
her that's just a random poles you never
took a pole dancing class after scene
you know it's impacted me so much I
think about you girls inspiring a [ __ ]
was crazy
Kate shirt gets your bag get your bag I
can't believe you worked I want to yeah
I worked I won in Austin
really yes I was in Vegas and it was
crazy I don't think the way Austin was
that crazy but I think we had that you
know that Farrah Abraham's girl the Teen
Mom or whatever like oh she went through
there for a little while she was like a
resident resident she is a dancer I kind
of feel like if you have a brand deal or
something you can but that's it guys we
need to do a class and then get a
residency yeah the big movie girls at
little D's yeah I mean so definitely
like being moved little DS being a
stripper probably not like the thing you
need to shoot for in life no hates of
strippers but like taking a stripper
pole class I mean that is athletic it is
dance it is a lot of other things and I
think it's very hopeful just seeing it
sounds crazy but I don't
no there's a number of different ways
but seeing another woman feel
confidently Satine is inspiring ahead of
your comfort zone I think that was the
biggest thing for me because I'm always
I was always like oh I'm just not that
way I'm not sexual I don't like sexual
attention you know so like I and just
not that so getting out of the comfort
zone and stop telling myself that story
was the biggest breakthrough for peace
we can see your clothes have a big like
apologize on expression I think so I
think so too and sometimes it's hard to
know what that expression is but stitch
fix makes it really easy for you to fill
out a survey and find your personal
style and then they assign you to a
stylist that will then pick clothes out
for you to match that style how easy is
that you basically does it try to
describe your style in one word simple
sophisticated adventurous and then when
you know when it comes to shopping for
clothes most of us are amateurs but then
with stitch fix you get a professional
to handle it a stylist does all the work
for you and they deliver your favorite
clothing shoes and accessories including
brands you know and love as well as
exclusive styles you won't find anywhere
else and they come you you complete your
style profile and the expert will send
you a hand-picked box of items based on
your style there's no subscription
required you can pick between automatic
shipments or you can get new pieces on
demand and shipping and returns are
always free plus the $20 styling fee is
automatically applied towards anything
you keep from your box so you're
basically getting 20 bucks off I got my
box and I was kind of nervous because I
feel like it's hard to nail my style you
know I say especially if you don't know
exactly yeah what your style is yet and
I was actually shocked they every I
picked I saved everything like I ended
up keeping everything from my box
because I liked everything so much it
had a variety of colors they looked good
with my skin tone I had this jacket that
I've been wearing every single day yeah
I've seen you wear at four times I never
would have picked it to like a lot of
those items I would not go into a store
and know to pick but that's why you have
a stylist picking yeah were you
so to get started today you can go to
stitch fix calm slash mood and get an
extra 25% off when you keep everything
in your box that stitch fixed calm slash
mood sticks fix calm slash mood and you
know what guys in 2020 we're gonna raise
those titties up comfortably no no crazy
wires no intense stiffness because we're
using third love bra I love them love oh
we love thirdly I like your boobs in
third love so comfy like I just want to
squeeze them you have that's third love
just good Devils really nice Wow Nikki
you got some great moves there love it
gets an I only have 1/3 Lavoie and mine
is black
I get disappointed where I'm wearing a
shirt where I need a beige bra please
send me another bra we need more yeah
third love please send more I have the
kind that goes down it has the sheer
right here showing us all of her boobs
I'm waiting for it to happen again
but I'll find her quiz because I didn't
even know I was not wearing a bra that
fit me before it like I just thought oh
this is not browser but you know how you
can get that little space between the
cups and your small boob problem I
didn't know that that wasn't supposed to
happen and then it like the straps would
dig into my shoulder so the fit finder
thing that quiz thing that they have you
do made it so that I actually got a bra
that fit me that fit my baby boobs and
it also also you don't have that problem
with the straps falling off and they
have half sizes too so they have sizes
for every breast shape size dimension
that you couldn't possibly think of and
when I got mine I filled out my fit quiz
and I I didn't do it right I did not
really do it right I got my bra and it
didn't really fit but I decided okay let
me they always say let's try again then
they ask you the most direct questions
is it the strap
is it the ban is it the cut like you
just say yes no yes no yes no and I was
like okay let me try this I sent it back
and within 48 hours I had the brand new
bra and it was perfect it was absolutely
amazing customer so yeah the customer
service is absolutely great and when you
did return that other bra that you did
wrong though third love donates all of
their gently-used returned bras to women
in need supporting charities in their
local San Francisco Bay Area and across
the United States so 2/3 lip knows where
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering our listeners
15% off your first order go to third
love comm slash big mood now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase
that's third love comm / big mood pay
for 15% off today mmm yeah yeah get sexy
in a new bra fitting with our strip club
so you could take it off I'm still
thinking about that woman I love her
great I've never even seen her but your
description I feel like I know her and I
am inspired yeah my dumb ass just
standing there with my tray just
watching this happen I don't even think
I moved like I really do not think that
people like where are our drinks they're
still waiting yes that's literally what
happened who Leah yes
when did you like where wouldn't you
first started embracing this like new
Julia did it feel weird to be out of
your comfort zone or how did that start
of infiltrate into your life and become
you damn um I honestly feel like it just
literally had to come from within yeah
so I think when I when I was like
feeling a lot happier and and just like
seeing all of you guys thrive I'm just
like I want to thrive like that too
like I want to I want to be in that
position too but then like I was fully
aware that I wouldn't get there if I
didn't try and now it's full circle
cause I'm like look at Julia thriving I
want to thrive like that
I know I mean I still look to you guys
I'm like damn they're doing something in
their lives right now what am i doing I
don't know what they're doing but they
doing it mr. cigar there's gotta be
something good yeah nailed it I do feel
like the mood definitely does make a big
factor into like you trying to have a
glow up because I think for me it's just
like I think I started becoming really
happy when I felt like I found my soul
mate don't get a big head are you gonna
tell us so much about him or your
relationship status and where you guys
are at are you married we talked about
marriage together now about three years
now
if we don't get down on one knee after
two and a half and we're coming up on it
with another five months.that that's my
voice three years till 30 Union Julie
are you you're 30 now right oh okay so
much anyone picture her being 30 or
still 24 feel like I'm still 24 yeah do
sometimes when people ask you to my age
I literally have to pause it like wait
how old am i yeah and then and then I
also feel like I'm 24 because I feel
like I'm doing things when I should like
when I should have done them when I was
24 you're not doing things yeah I feel
like I'm not an adult like legit I had
like two cousins I visited me from Texas
and they're like 9 and 11 and like we
were having this debate whether I was
the kid or elles an adult oh I dunno
baiting a child whether you're in charge
yes I need to defend that title
dare you call me the a word I would just
say we had a tie okay I'm just imagining
like an eight year old kid looking at
Julian he's like I'll show you like
anime so you know you are kids you know
what I love about kids as they as that
20s old for them so they always think
I'm like 20 like yes I'm very old I'm
twenty thirty they're like that age
doesn't even exist they're like where's
your gray hair damn they're just trying
to be smart about they're like no you're
an adult like scientifically you're an
adult and I was like no man I'm a kid I
still live at home guys come on right
after one or two yeah I was like mmm I
play game so like month I'm a kid please
you do you feel like is any of that like
affecting your self-esteem at all or do
you think it's it you don't even care
about any of that stuff because I know
there's a lot of societal pressure so
like be an adult and like all of that do
you do you feel anything about like stay
still living at home with their parents
or anything like that
Oh moving in with your boyfriend or you
know like doing the things that like
naturally you're supposed to be doing it
like really I think like maybe Julia
that was like maybe four years ago would
probably think kind of like that but I
think for me it's just like well it kind
of makes sense stay at home save up
money
it's just save up money so that I can
actually afford a house versus trying to
buy a house where I have no money and
I'll be like more in debt than is also
culturally like your first gen right I
don't see that's the thing I'm confused
cuz I can set myself second-gen because
my parents moved to over here and then
mm-hmm and then I you're the first or
your first gen of being born here
generation American because they're just
transplants yes yeah that's how we would
say it okay yeah they're just they're
just transplanted American they're not
true blooded American
yeah immigrated here yeah but no I don't
think like before I used to kind of
weird me out a little bit or at least
after college and I had to move back
home I was like damn I feel like a
failure because I didn't really
establish myself to like find like a
career where I could just like live
right next to like my workplace but it
didn't make sense because like I have no
money so we move yes well I mean a lot
of people in our age I guess in their
thirties are in a lot of debt too
because they try to hurry up an adult
super fast to like our if you're like
not in a lot of debt and you're just
like saving money and like doing things
a different way I think that's honestly
better we and college didn't used to
cost as much as it does now like you
didn't have used to have to get into
that much loan debt when our parents
were going to college it wasn't like how
it is for people now it's kind of nuts
when I hear how much my friends have to
pay for student loans still oh my god
like shocked yeah yeah like the other
day I found out that my mom pays for my
older sibling to stay at home and I was
like you pay them to stay at home but
you don't pay me when I'm living like
you got your Christmas time we all
stayed at the same hotel for on
Christmas Eve yes we usually stay at my
aunt's house but now everybody's like
grown up and got married and like
there's way too many people to stay
place so we stay at a hotel next to her
house and it we stayed at the Hyatt in
Long Beach and I booked our Steve and I
hotel room and everything then I found
out that my parents paid for my brother
and his wife so I was like you got money
now
you're gonna dull your Meriden sometimes
I feel like I'm playing dress-up cuz I I
still feel the same way where I'm like
I'm not a full grown adult yet and then
exactly mortgage lender calls and he's
like mr. Li mo green we want to talk to
you about refinancing your home and I'm
like oh [ __ ] they're talking to me like
I know [ __ ] you're my credit score yes
let me forward that to you and I will
get that to you sir person yeah yeah and
they're like we're also gonna you need a
letter from your CPA I'm like yes I my
CPA yes I will get on that send like my
tax forms out to my attack scribe you
like yeah you do that I don't know what
you need to do we do that just give me a
number
I always tried to there was a I don't
know if I've said this before on here
but there was a youtuber that said one
time that he tries to be really grateful
for everything that's going on because
he'll try to see everything through his
18 year old self sighs and so I did that
I had a regular day of like going into
work and when I was walking like up the
staircase to get to worry because like
I've said this before y'all I'll work in
now I know to 1/r and it's it's
beautiful it's absolutely beautiful it's
a multi-billion dollar company the
offices are like gorgeous you see like
all of these like business see people
walking in and out and so as I was
coming up the steps I tried to see it I
was like my 18 year old self because
it's such a good reminder of like how
far you've come you know so like the
ones don't really get blurred and I'm
like I walked up and it's almost like I
was talking to my younger self like is
this it it was like yeah this is this is
it this is what we do and like you like
little me was like holy [ __ ] this is
what we do I think there was like kind
of like that nervousness when I when I
see like no 18 year old me was 10
[ __ ] years ago and just accepting
like your adulthood and like getting
that confidence and being proud of
yourself
knowing how far you've come after ten
years like there was one day we were at
we were out like we had all gone out for
drinks and Nikki started talking about
like oh that's where I used to waitress
and because I see current like
successful Nikki I cannot
imagine her taking my order I literally
cannot do it and for her it probably
just feels like it was a few years ago
and I'm like yeah absolutely not I still
feel like that waitress girl for sure
really I can still see the anxiety
attacks happening in the restaurant I'm
like oh my god did I put their appetizer
yet like and I I always try to remind
myself like how far that stuff is in the
past so that I'm always like so grateful
and present for like this moment I I
think that's also something that's
really helped me be more confident and
appreciative of like how far I've come
you know totally yeah I am I recently
put your boner way I think I've
mentioned that I've kept a daily journal
since I was 15 for me it was really
therapeutic when I was back a depressed
lonely a kid and then you know
transitioned into if depressed lonely
adult like I did enough depressed lonely
in my adult life but yeah so I mean I
still struggle with depression we'll get
into that later but anyway the point is
one of the exercises that I did I was I
think it was from the book the artists
way I think it was from that book but I
wrote out in 2012 I wrote out like who I
hoped that I would be when I was 30 and
I like wrote out like I want to own
property in LA and like it was like big
like I want a husband that loves me just
as much as I love them and they do these
things and they're this way and I wrote
out all the things that I remember
writing those out I didn't remember that
I wrote it till I found it but then it
flashed me back to writing those out
feeling like I was writing the
impossible down I was just like I guess
I'll write down like what I would go so
far as my dreams yeah but like I
remember bawling crying after writing
those because I was like I'm never gonna
get these and then I found that and
there was a blank page next to that and
I answered my previous self it was from
2012 like did we get there and I go well
actually we did get this one and here's
what he's like and here's his name and
this and then I was like and yeah
we did actually buy property in Los
Angeles here's where we live this is our
zip code and it looks like this and and
then like some of the things like didn't
get but I was like but we're working on
it we're actually like pretty close to
getting this thing and then I wrote a
letter to my 40 year old self like hey I
really hope we're here here here and
here did we get there and I think you
know I guess I'll revisit that when I'm
40 but it was so humbling to like read
back on that and look through the eyes
of that was I was even older than 80 no
I think it was twenty four or whatever
and I like looking through those eyes
again of I remember being in my studio
apartment not knowing how I was gonna
pay rent having 89 cents in my bank
account choosing to feed my cats over
myself and being like I want to buy
property in LA dreams are coming true I
saw I saw on Twitter the other day
lil nas ex had posted a video he posted
a video and it was like I took this
exactly one year ago January 9th like
something and he walks into frame and
he's in his house eating a box of the
Little Caesars Pizza and he's like it's
January 9th 2018 old town road just
dropped and I got nine hundred plays and
I just went up a bunch of followers and
he was like I guess I'll revisit this in
a year and then he did his one year post
a year later in his mansion wearing all
white with then he's like you know this
song has a billion plays or something
and and it reminded me that so much can
happen in just one year if you make it
happen
mm-hmm and I mean it happens like that
like even you you were like you were
really like really to prosecute you're
like just kill me like I feel when I
think about it that was just a few
months ago but when I know like where
you are now just isn't gonna [ __ ]
like she will kill you she really just
might give a [ __ ] and it happened just
like that and it was it happened because
she wanted it to and so much in your
life can change in one year and it will
go by so fast but you have to want it
and you have to make happen yeah I
really like it was you Michael too
[Laughter]
happen for you you could run here now -
wanna write also like you my little
pedicure in my little do you have any
specific goals or do you have anything
that you're gonna try to do in 2020 or
what are your plans I know your
boyfriend has a little company that you
guys are working yeah yeah there yeah so
we want to make that grow we want to
make that grow but in terms of the end
goal for that I'm not quite sure yet
because we're still kind of talking
about it but we do want stat boosts and
plug it in there stat boost to grow well
link in the description to check a toast
yeah it's just for all you gamers out
there if you guys game what's the what's
idea behind it so the idea behind it is
that he wanted to create a brand that
would inspire people to be like the best
versions of themselves and it's just
like like in in every game or not in
every game but in some games where you
can choose your character how you look
like or like what kind of class you want
to be so like you want to be like in
magic or do you just want to be like
someone who just gets into like I don't
know I don't know all the terms but it's
like when you get into like the physical
fights or like if you like handle guns
or whatever you know you could you get
to choose you know and like in those
games you get to choose who you want to
be right so essentially with this brand
you know he wants you to be able to like
hey we're here to support you you know
in your life and and we're here to be
like kind of an accessory that like you
know to kind of give you that push to
the to do like that's not only like when
you're playing games and having fun but
like in real life
get out and actually try to be the best
version of yourself yeah that's a great
message yes let's do that stuff yeah
yeah thanks but yeah no I mean I agree
with bozo I mean I feel like a lot can
happen in a year but you gotta want it
yeah you gotta want it and so I think
and believe it yeah that it can happen
because there was I there was a phase
within JK where I think it was doing
super duper well like I think of the
year of 2015 yeah it was funny and and I
just remember like everybody was getting
like hit up with brand deals and went
and like some some companies reached out
to me but every time I saw those things
I'm like oh my god like like they really
want me to work on does like oh no no I
do with your own value I didn't see my
own value so then like fear of success
being being afraid of that like I never
gave them a quote or price like I never
really responded to them because I was
like oh I'm thankful that you think I'm
somebody of value but then I don't feel
that right so then I felt like I missed
out on a lot of opportunities that could
have happened if I had just believed in
myself yeah totally yeah and so like now
like one other brands reach out to me
I'm just like [ __ ] yeah yeah let's do
this
yeah because cuz to me I was like well
what have I accomplished over these past
years personally for me like on a
personal level and what I wanted to do
and I just felt like I didn't do as much
as I could and so you learned from that
I do yeah and that's why I like I'm
trying to be as like proactive now and
I'm trying to like do things that I
normally wouldn't do just to try them
and then if I don't like it then I at
least I know because I tried yeah yeah
it always like takes me aback when
people are like ooh won't even try
something they'll be like well I'm just
not that and I don't I won't never be
good at some people are naturally good
like so I remember just recently people
have been like well I'm not that
organized like you're really organized
and I'm not I'm like [ __ ] this happened
because I was so disorganized and I
gotta get my life together
and I was like I'm just not an organized
person and then one day I was like wait
why can't I be and then I just started
watching tutorials on how to get more
organized and well I'm not really a good
singer like can I just all of a sudden
that all the sudden you put in the work
so anybody can learn how to sing a tune
extent like the technique behind it yeah
very interesting almost anyone can and
like you guys bring up such an
interesting point that I just realized
if you set attainable goals for yourself
whether it be I want to be in the best
shape of my life or I want to own a
condo or I want to move to a new state
and start over
you will never the complete opposite of
that will never happen you know does
that make sense like you will never sink
any lower than you are it's not like
you're your house currently is gonna
burn down if you go for that what's
gonna happen is maybe you may not hit
the Mar either you hit it or you hit
just below the belt of what you want you
know for the moon so if you miss you hit
the stars yeah like if you if you really
want a condo you're like I want to own a
condo in LA in LA by the end of the year
you save and you save and you save and
maybe by the
the year your $20,000 short of it but
whether you have now $80,000 that you
wouldn't have had if you hadn't got that
goal if you say I want to be in the
healthiest shape of my life then either
by the end of year you'll be in the
healthiest shape or you'll be just below
the belt you have to set those goals in
order to even start moving and then
create habits that get you there yeah
sure and it will happen naturally it's a
very law of its rights we r2 because
I've set so many goals too and like if I
could see myself ten years ago I would
never guess that I would be here right I
don't even feel like I tried that hard
but just because I thought about certain
things they still came true
like I allowed myself to think like oh
what could happen if I was in this girl
group like should I accept being in this
girl group and being on camera should I
accept doing these things like I just
think about it and like it just happens
and you know so good exercise to do if
you're thinking it you're like I don't
know I it's hard for me to believe that
things could happen instead of putting
that much pressure on yourself saying
things like well wouldn't it be nice if
fill in the blank wouldn't it be nice if
I could fit into my old clothes wouldn't
it be nice if I could own a condo in LA
and then it allows your mind to dream
and like actually picture it and start
visualizing it rather than putting
pressure like okay I got to get there
like if that's if that scares the [ __ ]
out of you
and I think that's kind of what you were
one of the biggest things I noticed like
if I was doing that when I go back home
and I don't want to like talk trash
about everyone back home but there is a
different kind of magic in LA like when
you move here you kind of surround
yourself with people who think
differently and then but when I go home
I notice a lot of people still think
very negatively so like a lot of people
are still like oh I could never do that
or I'm just stuck here this is just the
way it is you know like yeah all the way
you don't allow themselves to think
greater than that and I was like that
when I first got here too and I I don't
feel like I fit into the group that well
because I still have them in tality I
was still kind of negative I was still
like oh well it's just not like that
like that's just not possible electing
yourself from what you think might be
failure yeah and then over the years
like people around me slowly kind of
beat that out of me and they're like no
these they're these possibilities are
realistic if you let them you know come
to you so there's so many things that
you can do for yourself if you just let
go of like oh it's not possible oh for
sure
yes the universe is not gonna get in
your way you are gonna get in your only
you yeah oh yeah and limitations you
build for yourself via and even when a
situation arises it's less an ideal if
you let that situation affect you for
more than 48 hours it's you oh yeah
really sure I heard something one time
and you know forgive me that I'm
probably not articulating this well but
they said that you know when something
bad happens for the first two days it's
a reaction and then you know the month
after it could become a depression and
then for a year after it's now a
personality trait and you have the power
to stop that from happening so it you
know it like it's it's all on you and
the perception that you put on yourself
and the world and the best thing you can
do is change that change that filter and
like love yours down yeah only ways to
do it yeah yeah loving yourself is
definitely important that's how because
gotta do it I know I mean even I feel
like every year whenever I try to set
goals for myself it's just more of like
this year I want to be more confident
and like every year it slowly builds up
to that and like so to answer earlier
it's like yeah I just want to be more
confident be more comfortable in my own
skin yeah because I mean I don't know
for me it's just like when I have some
like somebody or like people that I
really like around me like I kind of
want to perform and be the best version
well there's a lot of averages that you
become the average of the five people
you spend the most time with so if
you're constantly spending time with
people who are doing things and
achieving things and they're like being
the type of person you want to be you're
gonna slowly become that whether you
like it or not yeah yeah and vice versa
so if the people are around you being
toxic and sad and like you know negative
you're gonna become toxic and sad and
negative whether you like it or not so
so that's why I attribute my globe to
all you guys and also it's just like
yeah
it's only you that's the roadblock right
like you are your own roadblock and I
feel like if there's things that you're
not happy with in your life you should
definitely just be proactive in trying
to change it because I think for the
longest time like in college especially
like I felt like I didn't really like my
body very much like it wasn't bad but it
wasn't just to what
wanted right and I just remember like
telling myself was like well the reason
why it's not - how you want is because
you're not working out those areas so
that it would be like I mean you you're
the one that put yourself here exactly
or the reason why you're this so like I
never really like harped on that so much
because like oh I understand why my
body's like this and it's because of
this and if I really want to change it
then I would do it so are you gonna do
it or you're not gonna do it yeah so I
just did it and I was like cool and I
feel like yeah working out really does
like help with the globe because you're
like yeah it's simple but it's not easy
yeah I'm sort of the work thank you so
much for being here Julia we loved
having you anytime in where can they
find you you can find me on instagram at
X blue apples with the X and then the
color blue apple and then a Z at the end
yeah we're gonna yeah and you can also
find me on my youtube too with the same
name oh and the links will be in the
description too if you want to check
that out be sure to rate us on iTunes do
all that stuff subscribe we got a lot of
cool [ __ ] coming out this year and I
don't want you to miss it so be sure you
subscribe hit that like button and we
love you we'll see you next time